people have said some vile things to me
you know about my whole Indonesia thing
oh this is good oh this is going to give
the anarchists and Lee chess
let's go what's the Indonesian thing
yeah the way you said okay maybe we
don't want to talk about it no no but
let's let's talk no it's it's it's
totally fine I who did you kill I didn't
I I was gonna say I wish but I'm not
even sure I can make a joke like that I
uh so the Indonesia thing was I was
streaming
chess on chess.com I might add
uh and I got booted up a 10 minute game
just a random account from Indonesia
that was the flag now mind you on
these websites you can pick your flag
can be from wherever you don't it's not
geotracing you can change it I was like
okay I come from Indonesia and as always
I looked at the account because it was a
Untitled high rated account
and look through the games
win rate was suspiciously High average
accuracy was suspiciously High
it's like okay I think this is a cheater
I said it out loud it's not the first
time I played cheaters on stream
and I saw okay I'm still gonna play
Let's see what happens
the game was not crazy suspicious but
definitely suspicious a few critical
moments where I just clearly thought I
had a good position and then the person
or the bot played some move that just
killed my hopes and I lost
okay I lost and I wrote to the chess.com
Fairplay team like behind the scenes I
wasn't even saying anything publicly on
stream and Gaga banned it was cheater
so that night
oh right before I'm going to sleep
because Indonesia is 12 hours ahead of
New York go my Twitter
the hell is going on I see hundreds of
responses to my recent tweets Levy you
gotta check Facebook man you gotta check
Facebook like so you got here's a link
so
allegedly that account belonged to an
older gentleman
and his son made a Facebook post that
said
my dad played a big streamer in chess
Gotham chess and Gotham got mad he lost
to my dad so his community Mass reported
my dad and he was banned for cheating
oh it went viral oh no did you know that
in Indonesia has the fourth largest
population
in the world I didn't know I learned it
the hard way interesting tens of
thousands of DMS every second Wow
Instagram DMS because I had my DMs open
I was never afraid of that stuff uh my
YouTube videos went from 99 of vote down
vote
50 50. oh wow they swarmed myself all
negative oh no all play him again you I
I mean I don't know how much swearing
there is on this podcast but I mean it
was just all sorts of all the [ __ ]
swearing uh they
just everything ruthless The Vicious
they were going to kill me they were
going to rape my family they were going
to they were contacting people I
followed on Instagram they were
contacting them and telling them crazy
things it was I'm not joking it was tens
of thousands of people every minute it
was unbelievable and I didn't know what
to do because the guy cheated I was in
the right yeah people how certain were
you that he cheated 100 okay 100 I'm
okay I don't know if you can say 100 but
suggest.com had also had a suspicion
they once they have like good they have
the good detection algorithms yes Danny
wrench would be able to I legitimately
know nothing about the behind the scenes
because it's only kind of tech people
but uh what one thing I did not realize
was that this account whether it was the
sun playing or the father playing we
will not know we don't know who played
it could have been the sun it could have
been the dad covering for him whatever
but
at some point that account won 27 games
in a row at 95 accuracy I mean even
Magnus can't do that even
you know uh
this took a month this story took one
month from start to finish first I had
to work with a like a media company to
Geo block my content in Indonesia on
YouTube so Indonesians could not see my
channel oh so you you didn't want to
like lean into it Go full Donald Trump
no no let's let's uh because you're in
the right you feel like you're in the
right you as far as you know you're in
the right yeah and I hated watching all
my work burn to the ground like oh you
felt it was being yeah and I'm one thing
I'm learning about myself is I'm not a
good crisis actor I need someone to like
slap me so I don't do something
emotional in the moment when crisis is
ongoing what would be the emotional act
that's not productive there
partnering with an MCN that makes you
give away a bunch of your revenue and
then when you break with them I wasn't
monetized for a week it was a very big
decision to plug in I think they're
called mcns but what are they sorry I
don't what are they they're like we
there's there's specialized agencies
that work behind the scenes with YouTube
yeah that if you connect your account
they say they can give you certain ad
benefits they can Geo block your content
they which you can't do normally they
have certain perks that only YouTube
allows behind the scenes you pay them
ten percent of your monthly ad Revenue
but they claim to do a handful of things
for you I just needed them to geoblock
my content I I just didn't I didn't care
how much money I was uh going to give
away per month but so why geoblock it
you just didn't like the
the downboarding
yeah I didn't want you wanted a
positivity more like you're being
educational you're I mean they're like
you do a bit of [ __ ] talking but it's
more like fun and easy going you didn't
want this kind of viciousness yeah my
comment section was just being
completely flooded like they were
destroying my channel and to be honest
maybe all of the views and the downvotes
out of would have actually been
beneficial maybe I mean my videos would
have actually started getting
recommended to more people yeah but I'm
a person this is Hill goes back to the
same oh so this got to you yeah this was
like I was just watching it and I'm like
this is not fair this is I don't I don't
know what to do so I'm gonna stop this
as much as I can they still got through
their VPN and they were like you [ __ ]
you don't think we have VPN in Indonesia
it was this whole you know it was this
whole thing
um
this father and son got invited to every
major News Network I'm not joking they
got invited to the major podcast they
like to say The Joe Rogan of Indonesia
yeah Daddy corbosier is this Mentalist
he's a bald guy very fun guy he had them
and that's when the Indonesian Chess
Federation stepped in the thing is
nobody who was harassing me knows
anything about Chess they just saw the
story
and a long story short they brought in a
sponsor the guy played a strong uh one
of the strongest chess players in the
country who also happens to be a woman
Irene sukhandar she's like 2400
International Master she crushed them
because his actual playing strength is
thirteen hundred fourteen hundred you
something like that he still got paid
because there was a winning price point
a losing price fund and we never heard
from him again
and that was the whole search that was
that was why I had to shut down all of
my social media to DMS and DM requests
and even notifications like I don't get
notifications unless it's someone I
follow but see stuff like that doesn't
often get resolved in this kind of clear
way no it doesn't it could have been so
you got lucky there that there's um
a conclusion to this yeah somebody got
views somebody got money
uh and
I never got I never got many apologies
what did you learn from that experience
about yourself about about the internet
I think first and foremost I learned
that
every moment
you are live or broadcasting can be
completely blown out of proportion you
have to be real careful and
I can't actively think about that
unfortunately even when I'm streaming
I've had other instances
where things come back to bite I've even
had these moments live on stream I feel
like I said something too sarcastically
to somebody and I don't know how their
day is going in my ruin their whole day
you know God God knows what you have
these moments of regret where you want
your personality to shine through and
you want to entertain
at least you're thinking at what cost
if I make a joke to a viewer that
suddenly the whole chat is laughing at
them
what if that puts them in a deep dark
place and again so it all comes back to
this one-on-one thing for me because I'm
a human I would hate to put another
person into that situation if I would
much rather get a drink with somebody
than then but it's all kind of part of
this act and you want to make jokes and
I also learned I'm a horrible crisis
actor so I have no patience but I think
that's normal in 2022 everything is
immediate we can barely sit
think let time go by